[Musik]
so damit thomas sind logischerweise bei
ihnen und wir wollen hier noch ganz
schnell wetten sie und ich sie haben
auch den vorteil zu sagen wer wird
bundeskanzler sie dürfen anfangen ich
halte dagegen und mein wetteinsatz ist
wenn sie gewinnen dann moderiere ich
eine unserer sendung viertel nach acht
eine unserer gemeinsamen sendung in
einem outfit ihrer wahl mit eurovisions
musik mit euro wie sie unter gut
also ich freue mich jetzt festlegen wer
bundeskanzler war sie wetten einfach und
ich halte dagegen naja ich wette das ist
es ist keine reine also ich kann ja
nicht meine wunschkandidaten sondern ich
muss dann ich sage dann scholz also ja
sie wetten auf stolz dann werde ich
damit auf armin laschet das nennt man
hätten was ist ihr einsatz ja mein
einsatz dass ich ich ich kann leider
etwas ist mir zu eng
dann also gut dann würde ich dann würde
ich einen weiteren einen weiteren bunten
abend bräuche gestalten großartig
herzlichen dank thomas gottschalk top
die wette gilt darf ich das war ein
großer moment für mich das einmal sagen
ich mache den die
atommacht den notar
[Musik]